from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Heinz products in the UK and the
US this is food Wars
[Music]
Heinz is best known for its ketchup in
the UK it comes in the following bottle
sizes
250 grams 342 grams 460 grams 570 grams
700 grams 910 grams or our largest size
a 1.35 kilogram bottle I did also find a
one kilogram bottle online and I ordered
some but unfortunately it was stolen
from the lobby of our building so just
imagine it there Heinz ketchup in the US
also comes in a variety of sizes down at
the end here we've got the 14 ounce
bottle then we go up to 20 ounce bottle
we have a 32 ounce bottle 38 ounce
bottle and the big juggie guy 114 ounces
what
this can't be for like a family I guess
if you just like dipping
your food and your fingers directly in
there
nice
[Music]
Apparently one serving size for ketchup
in the UK is 15 grams which means that
this bottle contains 90 servings we're
going to measure that out and see if it
seems realistic
so according to Heinz in the UK that's
one serving of ketchup that maybe looks
like a bit less than what I might
normally have with my meal if I was
having say chips or something else which
required dipping but not too bad the U.S
serving size is one tablespoon which
Heinz says is 17 grams of ketchup let's
take a look at that right now
got to do this you wanna get that
ketchup water that comes out first
that's the worst thing in the world you
don't do this get that ketchup water
it's like well that's ruined oh it's
like oh 10 13.
this is like when you're getting gas you
want to get the exact dollar amount I've
been training for this my whole life
yay
there's a ketchup that means that this
114 ounce jug contains 190 servings of
this right here that seems that seems
like a reasonable amount
[Music]
there are all the Heinz products from
the UK that you won't find in the US we
finally have way more than America come
on and here are all the Heinz products
in the US you won't find in the UK do
they have more than us I feel like we
have more let's find out in the UK we
can get two exclusive varieties of
ketchup we're gonna ketchup with 50 less
added sugar and salt as well as ketchup
with no added sugar and salt and these
are exclusives here in the us because we
have them singularly a no salt added and
a no sugar added some of the exclusive
ketchups we have are jalapeno ketchup oh
Sriracha flavored ketchup
oh
not bad but just tastes more garlicky
than anything else hot and spicy Tabasco
ketchup also we have ketchup with a
blend of veggies kids approved I mean
I'm assuming this is the trick kids and
eating more vegetables I think it's
better than none right I'm curious
it tastes exactly like ketchup which is
good right trying to trick kids eating
vegetables this is it you can also get
simple tomato ketchup with no artificial
sweeteners and tomato ketchup sweetened
only with honey not available at the
time of filming this segment well the UK
might lack in exclusive ketchup options
we make up for with our mayonnaise over
here we can get light mayonnaise the
existence of light mayo implies the
existence of a forbidden dark Mayo just
a heads up we have a vegan May option
other vegan options include this vegan
chili mayo as well as this vegan Mayo
slash garlic aioli then we have some
seriously good mail options including
this garlic and caramelized onion one as
well as this rich and creamy truffle
Mayo I don't like how they've had to
create a fancy brand of mayo I feel like
nobody should be too good for Mayo if
you think you're too good for Mayo
you're wrong the Heinz website also
advertised a lemon and black peppermo
which unfortunately I couldn't find
anywhere the mustard option you get in
the U.S exclusively are the 100 natural
spicy brown mustard Heinz 100 natural
honey mustard and of course organic
yellow mustard Hein sells two types of
mustard in the UK a mild mustard and a
honey mustard but they were strangely
hard to track down I did find the mild
mustard online but that was also one of
the things stolen along with our ketchup
so enjoy that as well barbecue sauces
USA we love our barbecue we love our
barbecue sauces the first one is the
Carolina mustard style sweet mustard
barbecue sauce I'm like stoked for this
one these one of these arrived I was
like hell yeah I want to try these
sauces
oh
fantastic yep we got the Carolina
vinegar style sweet and tangy barbecue
sauce
I like this one too
there's a Kansas City style sweet and
Smoky Barbecue sauce I could not get at
the time of filming this but I was able
to get the original sweet and thick
barbecue I mean barbecue sauce is like
the best thing ever
well they weren't kidding that is thick
the Texas barbecue sauce bold and spicy
just like the state
also thick oh my goodness I did this one
or this one these are the two best ones
I can't decide Carolina or Texas we only
have two barbecue sauce options in the
UK a sweet barbecue sauce and a classic
barbecue sauce I'm not sure how it
compares to the original sweet option in
the US or how they've managed to kind of
isolate those two flavors I don't think
like Original Classic can be a flavor in
itself
vinegars let's go distilled white
vinegar five percent acidity what does
it mean by five percent acidity great
question well you see
I have no idea uh then we also got the
Heinz Gourmet malt vinegar we also have
a salad vinegar gourmet salad vinegar
yum we have a gourmet tarragon vinegar
all-natural apple cider vinegar a
organic unfiltered apple cider vinegar
with the mother question mark question
mark question mark yeah I don't know
what that means either uh we have a
Heinz all natural multi-purpose Extra
Strength vinegar with a six percent
acidity and of course the Heinz imported
balsamic vinegar from Modena while in
the UK Heinz just has malt vinegar which
I couldn't find today but it does go
great on your fish and chips we have got
so many gravies gravy as I know it you
pour it on mashed potatoes and sometimes
turkey it's like a brown sauce sometimes
a white sauce you also get biscuits and
gravy for breakfast which is fantastic
that sauce is white we got a lot of
different variations of gravy I can't be
the U.S gravy Ambassador all right I
didn't ask for this job at no point in
the interview and I was like well you
know a lot about gravies right and if I
said I did I lied all right please
revoke my gravy Ambassador status and
I'm sorry for deceiving the people of
food Insider Heinz home style gravy with
mushroom there's mushrooms in it I see
gravy twice a year once at Thanksgiving
and once when I go to Jollibee and then
you got the Savory beef gravy Bistro aju
signature gravy rich and savory made
with roasted turkey let's go we got the
country style sausage gravy this goes
yes he's pouring it on biscuits is it
breakfast it's a breakfast gravy it
comes with a country sausage and hash
browns recipe Joe I don't know what that
is but that is not gravy that looks
horrific especially that creamy stuff
like why is it white gravy should never
be white classic chicken this is like
not white it's more of like a khaki
colored gravy now that isn't even close
to the amount of gravies you can get in
the U.S I went to several grocery stores
several looking for these gravies as
many as I could find so I'm gonna rattle
off the list Signature rich and savory
gravy with real roasted chicken the home
style brown with onion gravy Heinz homes
now classic chicken fat free gravy
Homestyle pork gravy and last but not
least homestown Savory beef fat free
gravy
British gravy is either made from the
juices and drippings of a roast dinner
or made by adding water to some gravy
granules not a Heinz brand just a good
brand I like this though thankfully we
don't have any of that American gravy in
the UK but what we do have is salad
cream or Salad queen as it's currently
called in honor of the Queen's Platinum
Jubilee it's just what Liz would have
wanted I'm sure now Americans don't be
alarmed by salad cream I know the name
sounds a little off-putting but it's
actually not that bad it's basically
just Mayo that they've added some kind
of vinegar and also a little bit of
sugar too so it's kind of like a Tangy
Mayo which you can add to your salads or
to your sandwiches I feel like with
Americans some of the things that they
pass off as salads they have no right to
criticize a salad cream you ever seen I
think it's like ambrosia salad In
America which is basically just loads of
mayo anyway pickles and relish I think
relish is just okay not a fan of pickles
uh the hot dog relish why is it this
color
why is it the scholar if I got a hot dog
and they put this relish on it I'd be
like yeah you're making it again without
that dill relish right just
straightforward from dill pickles or
they added Dill to it what do you think
Burger fans get yourself a hamburger
dill chips other pickle stroke relish
options that we have here in the US are
genuine whole original sour dill pickles
spicy garlic chips with garlic and red
pepper sweet and spicy chips with
crushed red pepper sweet gherkins we
don't have Heinz pickles in the UK but
we do have Heinz pickle this is an
important distinction to make in the UK
is if you ask for just pickle singular
on your sandwich you'll end up with this
this is an iconic British condiment
which is either served as part of your
plowman's lunch or on a sandwich like a
cheese and pickle it's a thick condiment
made with some cooked vegetables like
carrots sweets cauliflower and onions
all served in this kind of thick Tangy
sauce we also have Heinz piccolilly in
the UK it's sort of similar to
parliament's pickle and that it's a
spreadable condiment with some crunchy
cooked vegetables inside but it's also
different because it's got the mustard
base which gives it this distinctive
yellow color I will say it's kind of an
old person's condiment I don't think
you'll really see anyone under the age
of like 50 or so in the UK rushing for
the piccolilly but it is tasty next up
Heinz us offers a bunch of specialty
sauces Heinz 57 sauce real talk I've
never heard of this before this video
video it says an add zest to chicken
steak or pork this is gonna sound like a
weird thing to say but doesn't this look
really good so
let's find out first the sniff test
I like how it smells I like how it
smells
there we go
yeah that's really good I can't place my
finger on exactly what it is ah secret
blend of Premium herbs and spices oh man
it's like liquid KFC apparently
it's like like a mustard base but like
sweet or zesty or like punctuation to it
oh 967
chili sauce I gotta say Heinz to be put
in this great on Burgers and Fries let's
talk about my sauce on I'll brush my
teeth with this if I want to You're
Gonna Stop Me
yeah hmm
that would be great on my burgers or and
or fries the Heinz original cocktail
sauce I'm not opening this you know the
shrimp you get it cocktails I have no
opinion on cocktail sauce Worcestershire
sauce couldn't get my hands on it I do
think that's weird that Heinz also makes
his own work Worcestershire sauce
Worcestershire Worcestershire is that
right now they also own Leah and perrins
so are they competing against themselves
I don't think so I think they just
bought it because they're Heinz you
think like I'm not getting the Heinz
Worcestershire sauce I'm getting the
Leanne perrins that joke's on you Heinz
gets paid on all that first thing that
should be specialty sources with the
extra eye and secondly in the UK we also
have a range of specialty condiments we
have an American style Smoky baconaise
sauce and also an American style burger
sauce these actually look or feel
American to you Joe yes that looks like
salsa would potentially have then we
have a Thai style sweet chili sauce
British people love Thai sweet chili
sauce I don't know where that
Association came from but I'm not even
playing because it's delicious then we
have a Turkish style garlic sauce I
think this is kind of a nod to the
Turkish style Kebab shops which are so
popular in the UK drunk Kebab is one of
the best Pleasures in life speaking of
junk food we also have Heinz curry sauce
in the UK you don't have to be drunk to
enjoy it but it does help cheesy chips
and curry sauce is a big British hit
next up we have a spiced pineapple
chutney as well as a North African style
spicy Kebab sauce made with chili and
onion why doesn't ketchup and mustard
come in the same bottle we all exclaim
to the heavens apparently Heinz has a
whole thing called sauces mixed by Heinz
because God forbid you do it yourself
some of these I mean I don't even know
you wanted them together to begin with
who knows how they figured this out
honey ratchet what do you think that is
surely you watching at home I understand
the value of having a bottle of sriracha
and a bottle of Honey the amount of
times you mix them must pale in
comparison
a lot of times you don't need to mix
them
actually that's pretty good though then
we got Mayo chip
yeah mayo and ketchup together at last
oh God nope even by these standards is
really bad up next
crunch crunch it's called Ranch and
ketchup two things I never combine
anyway oh it's like chunks of [ __ ] in it
too
of this one okay
both the ketchup connection ones those
taste so much exactly like Ranch and the
ketchup Mayo one was a Mayo chip tastes
just like Mayo buffer Ranch
I'll concede Buffalo Ranch in the same
thing I understand this one
oh that was the bottle not me
that was me
I went from hating this to loving it in
like two seconds
this might be genius I'm taking this one
this is actually pretty good and this
would go really good if any potatoes or
fries of course on chicken oh my god
with popcorn chicken this would be ideal
oh my God Mayo must
this one works just fine you know it's
like it tastes like a creamy a creamy
mustard you can also get yourself a
mayor Racha sauce and oh God and this
last one come on guys sweet cat chili
sauce which I'm assuming is sweet
ketchup and chili sauce ah
we only have one pre-mixed Source option
in the UK and it's this Saucy sauce I'm
not sure why they've gone with this name
instead of marriage up because as far as
I can see it is just mayo and ketchup
combined Another Thing Worth touching
upon is HP versus A1 Sauce the great HP
A1 divide I mean that's literally like a
a rip through the Atlantic Ocean it's a
sauce that's meant to be on meat mostly
steak and hamburgers in the UK Heinz
produces another iconic condiment HP
Sauce it's a sauce which is also
designed to be enjoyed with Meats like
sausages or on your bacon sandwich I'm
more of a ketchup on the bacon sandwich
guy but you do you you have to
understand that when A1 Sauce dropped it
was that time in the 80s where marketing
was so crazy effective obviously there's
no internet so y'all watch the same five
to ten channels and you couldn't look at
a TV without seeing an A1 steak sauce
commercial from like 1985 to 1989. ta-da
A1 steak sauce and it was on the table
and we just put it on and like you know
licking the knife like oh yeah hey one
look at us we got A1 this [ __ ] is nasty
I'm not nostalgic for it I don't like it
I don't put sauces On Meats like steak
oh God it's so Tangy HP Sauce is better
than this I forgot to bring my bottle to
give you an idea of just how British
this sauce is HP actually stands for
houses of Parliament as you can maybe
infer from the fact that they are right
there on the label HP source is part of
a subcategory of sources in the UK which
are called Brown sauces while it might
not sound very appetizing it's really
popular in the UK as evidenced by the
fact that it's not even the only Brown
Source Kraft Heinz producers we also
have daddy's brown sauce
yes this is a real thing it wouldn't be
a Heinz episode unless I talked about
baked beans in the UK Heinz doesn't just
manufacture condiments but also an
enormous range of canned goods the most
iconic of these is probably Heinz beans
I'd say Heinz is probably the gold
standard for baked beans in the UK as
you may know British people love to eat
baked beans with a range of dishes
including a full English breakfast
sausage mash and beans fish fingers
chips and beans and of course beans on
toast baked beans so I'm gonna say it
right off the bat gonna show my
american-ness right now beans for
breakfast sounds absurd now granted we
have
sausage gravy and potatoes and chicken
fried steak so I know that our
breakfasts are very questionable beans
for breakfast beans and toast no no no
no no no no thank you my only issue with
Heinz beans is the stupid beans with a
zed spelling I think it was part of some
marketing campaign from back in like the
80s or the 70s and they just never let
it go but I will say British beans are
generally served in quite a sweet
tomatoey sauce which does go with quite
a few dishes I feel like American beans
are different yeah beans like here like
they're baked they usually come in like
a a barbecue sauce or a barbecue like
sauce you get them at barbecue places
right like picnic food right beans
aren't even the only canned goods that
Hinds cells in the UK they have a huge
range of soups canned pastas and more
Pine soups are pretty highly regarded in
the UK I like the big soups because I
feel like a standard can of soup isn't
enough for an actual meal but some of
the other flavors are really good the
classic tomato can't really be beaten
Heinz canned pastas don't have quite the
same reputation but I will fight to the
death to defend the beef of ravioli I
ate so much about growing up and I still
have such a strong nostalgic attachment
to it that if anyone criticizes it you
know where to find me then there are
even more food options from Heinz in the
UK including jars of pasta sauce salad
dressings and veggie burger options
Heinz covers so many product areas in
the UK that they even have a huge range
of baby foods I picked up this peach
mango banana and apple one because it
sounds delicious and I am technically
older than four months so I think I can
eat this
foreign
's ketchup in the US tomato concentrate
from Red ripe Tomatoes distilled vinegar
high fructose corn syrup corn syrup salt
spice onion powder natural flavoring is
everything on the ingredients list for
ketchup in the UK Tomatoes Spirit
vinegar sugar salt spice and Herb
extracts contains celery and spice there
are a few obvious differences between
the two lists the spices listed are
slightly different with ours explicitly
containing onion powder that's not to
say the UK doesn't also contain onion
powder as it may just fall under the
spice and Herb extract subcategory in
the UK our label also explicitly lists
celery as an ingredient largely for
allergen purposes in the U.S our ketchup
is sweetened with both corn syrup and
high fructose corn syrup while the UK
they just sweeteners with sugar
Americans put corn syrup in absolutely
everything because it's cheaper for food
producers to use when compared to real
sugar that's because corn farmers in the
US receive huge subsidies from the
government more than 116 billion since
1995 leading to massive corn production
we also have tariffs which make it more
expensive to import real sugar there
isn't really a health difference when
comparing the consumption of sugar and
corn syrup but they can be a discernible
taste difference for example American
Coca-Cola is flavored with high fructose
corn syrup while Mexican Coke is
flavored with sugar when comparing the
taste of the two some people said that
the American version was an even sweeter
taste but also had a slightly chemical
flavor are there any other ingredients
to look out for across Heinz product
range in the U.S we have pickles that
contain polysorbate 80. a chemical used
in foods like pickles and ice cream as
an emulsifier and a soberizer a
sobelizer solubilizer
solubilizer the bad news is that studies
have suggested it can cause colon cancer
and mice you know what that means giving
them dancing rats
also in the U.S our Heinz colors it's a
sausage gravy with titanium dioxide this
is a white dye most commonly used in
paints and varnishes delicious juice in
food is controversial studies show it
has harmful effects on animals during
scientific tests leading the European
Union to ban it from use in Foods
starting in August of 2022. the use of
brexit however the UK is no longer bound
by EU rules about food unfortunately for
Brits and Americans our respective food
safety authorities have actually
disagreed with the EU ruling so we may
still see titanium dioxide popping up in
our food
[Music]
here's everything at 100 grams of
original ketchup in the UK 102 calories
0.1 grams of total fat of which zero
grams of saturates 23.2 grams of carbs
of which 22.8 grams are sugars and 720
milligrams of sodium here's everything
in 100 grams of ketchup in the U.S 117
calories no fat
29.4 carbs and of that 23.5 grams of
that is sugar and the sodium is 941
milligrams other than the Trace Amounts
of fat in the UK ketchup the U.S starts
to higher in every category now these
stats are for 100 grams of ketchup which
is roughly five times the recommended
serving size which is one tablespoon
that's still a surprising amount of
sugar and sodium just a hundred grams of
ketchup in the U.S contain almost half
your daily sugar allowance as well as 40
percent of your daily sodium this also
worth checking out the serving size
because companies have a habit of
underestimating these let's bring about
the serving size we measured earlier I
still think that's a little bit smaller
than what I'd normally add to my plate
so I'm going to add some more to it and
then figure out the stats for what I
think is a realistic serving size I
don't think that's unrealistic judge me
if you want essentially more than double
the recommended serving size coming in
at around 31 grams let's figure it out
okay so I've had fries I'd probably go
whatever
okay this is 20 grams ah that seems so
bad and also I don't I don't think I'm
eating I don't think I'm eating all that
I don't think all of this is getting my
body I think just to be smeared around
and so here in America not concerned
this one's for you papa I like pickled
onion I like pick a lily pickled cabbage
is all right with bubbling squeak on a
Friday night I like tomatoes but what I
do prefer is a little bit of I come you
can we come a little bit of cucumber oh
imagine when that dropped in like 1920
people would have lost their minds